die erste klima klage gegen die
bundesregierung von greenpeace von drei
bauernfamilien ist leider gescheitert es
geht aber ein grund warum das dennoch
ein gewinn für den klimaschutz sein
könnte fünf stunden wurde ja gerade eben
verhandelt und es war eine
bemerkenswerte verhandlung zu haben die
bauern gelegenheit bekommen selbst sich
zu wort zu melden dass es eigentlich ein
verwaltungsprozess zu seinem frühen
stadium nicht üblich sie haben szenen
applaus bekommen das hat mich persönlich
noch niemals in einem gericht erlebt
dass so was passiert ist und der
vorsitzende hat das auch nicht
unterbunden
die argumente der bauern und von
greenpeace waren eigentlich nicht
schlecht sie haben gesagt die
bundesregierung muss sich an ihren
eigenen zielen festhalten lassen
das problem ist verfassungsrechtlicher
natur und es hat mit gewaltenteilung zu
tun denn wenn man diesen wieder klar
jetzt stadt geben würde dann würde so
das argument des gerichts in die arbeit
in die politische arbeit der
bundesregierung hinein gewirkt werden
ein gericht würde also eine bestimmte
politik plötzlich durchsetzen und so
funktioniert das nun mal nicht die
politik läuft nach eigenen regeln
politiker können abgewählt werden
man kann sich politisch streiten aber
ein gericht kann nicht eine
bundesregierung zu bestimmten
politischen maßnahmen zu urteilen
dennoch ist diese verfahren sicherlich
ein gewinn gewesen für den klimaschützer
und auch greenpeace kann sich sicherlich
glücklich schätzen denn es wird immer
häufiger klagt um aufmerksamkeit für ein
bestimmtes thema zu generieren und gar
nicht unbedingt zu gewinnen natürlich
wurde greenpeace gerne gewinnen aber sie
freuen sich sicherlich auch über die
die öffentlichkeit die aufmerksamkeit
die das thema jetzt noch einmal bekommen
hat vielleicht legen sie rechtsmittel
ein und läuten damit noch eine weitere
runde ein
insofern haben die klimaschützer
verloren aber auch gewonnen